inside this low-key Santa Monica office
building Microsoft's plotting its TV
future and it's tied to this Xbox
entertainment studios is a unit of Xbox
created to make original TV shows this
is the startup with the help of
Microsoft led by longtime Hollywood
executive Nancy Callum Xbox Studios is
developing all sorts of shows a Steven
Spielberg produced Halo series a robot
thriller called humans planned live
coverage of the Bonnaroo Music Festival
a reality show on street soccer ahead of
the World Cup to watch you'll fire up
your xbox and if you're one of the 48
million members of its Online
Entertainment Network Xbox Live you may
be able to stream Xbox originals the
same way you'd watch Netflix or play
interactive video games Microsoft may
also strike partnership deals to
distribute some of the shows outside of
Xbox and shows will also be interactive
if you're up for it you'll be able to do
funky stuff gamers like to do that's
different than lying on your couch
watching cable Microsoft's doing this to
keep xbox loyalists happy but also to
broaden its reach it's estimated each
Xbox old is worth a thousand bucks and
purchases to Microsoft between game
shows and Xbox Live a number that would
climb if TV is a success original shows
also fit with Microsoft's goal of making
Xbox one an anchor of its home
entertainment network connecting to
other Microsoft devices like tablets and
phones traditional TV places do they
write on the walls like this is very
kind of holy tech
adding to that tech office feel a
ping-pong table a well stacked lunch
room and we commemorate all of our
successes by ringing this bill let the
games make that TV shows